just 5 years before the supposedly Evil
colonizer Christopher Columbus sailed
the ocean blue the Aztec sacrificed more
than 880,000 people at the consecration
of the Temple of tenoch tlon over the
course of just four days hernand Cortez
another supposedly evil colonizer
witnessed these precise sorts of
sacrifices when he arrived in 1521 to
the capital of Teno Tian where the Aztec
priests sliced open the chests of
sacrificial victims and offered their
still beating hearts as a sacrifice to
the demons before tossing their dead
bodies down the steps of the temple not
very nice we don't you would not like
that kind of colonialism now happily
Cortez conquered the Aztecs he stopped
the human sacrifice he ended the demon
worship and he introduced the natives to
Christianity all good news the Liberals
consider this a very bad thing the
Liberals don't seem to have much of a
problem with demons